>>Gulfport, Mississippi's
Harrison Central High School
hasn't changed much since
it was founded in 1957.
It still has sports
teams and cheerleaders.
It still offers practical
courses in subjects
like cooking and horticulture.
But over the past several years
there's been a quiet revolution
going on that has transformed
Harrison's curriculum.
In almost every classroom
cutting edge technology tools
are facilitating a
new way of learning.
>>During the guilded
age what could be said
about national politics.
Is it A, the republican party
held the majority of voters?
>>Narrator: Now history lessons
are as exciting as game shows.
>>What is your final answer?
>>Narrator: Digital cameras
help reveal the principles
of physics.
>>Donnie: Are we collecting?
>>Narrator: Probes
and laptops are used
in real world scientific
explorations.
>>They even use technology
to improve their nationally
ranked cheerleading squad.
>>Dianne: Okay, breathe
three times.
In with the good,
out with the bad.
And rest for just a minute.
>>When we had tryouts
we realized a lot
of our cheerleaders were not as
physically fit as they needed
to be to be able to go
through a competition routine
that it only lasts two minutes
but those two minutes are
jam packed with stunts.
So we try to come up with
a conditioning program
and we use the computers
and the probes
to tell us what the heart rate
was before they exercised,
and then what it was afterwards
and also the respiration.
>>Like without this
stuff we'd have no idea
like how much things have
changed in, you know,
where we started and
where we're at now.
It lets people know you know
that they've either been
working hard enough or they need
to work a little bit harder.
>>Narrator: Data from the
cheerleader workouts is given
to students in an Algebra
II class for analysis.
>>The cheerleaders
gave us the information
and we have plotted it
by using our calculators.
We used a thing called
linear regression
to get basically the
average increase or decrease.
>>Charlotte: These students
are just learning how
to graph equations and instead
of just plain graphing numbers,
we're graphing real data so they
can have something meaningful
for their work.
>>Narrator: Math teacher,
Charlotte uses technology
to help students
make connections
between abstract concepts
and real world applications
whether they're graphing local
hurricane tides-
>>On the tide tables
it was point seven feet
at twelve-oh-five P.M. which
our X values are the times
and Y values are-
>>Narrator: Or taking virtual
field trips around the world.
>>Teacher: We're going to
find antique carousels online
around the world.
>>Most of our kids never
get out of Harrison County
so when I can send kids
on a virtual field trip
around the world,
it's just amazing.
[Student playing instrument]
>>Right now I'm tracing myself
so I can determine my
velocity of the ball-
>>Narrator: In this physics
class students use video
cameras, photo gates, and
other high-tech gadgets
to explore the science behind
their personal passions.
>>Olivia Graves: If you
consider a minute ago you went
from up there to the floor
in a thirtieth of a second.
So your acceleration and
your average velocity was a
lot faster.
>>The idea that students are
actually going to benefit
from sitting in the desk all
day long I think is a fallacy
and a problem with education and
this gets them moving around,
discovering, learning.
Discovery to me is the most
important part of education.
>>I'm going to measure the
sound wave and the acceleration
or velocity of my strokes.
Like I thought this course was
going to be like oh my god,
physics formulas, math.
But actually when you're
actually doing things it makes
it fun.
>>Narrator: Fun is also
part of the lesson plan
for this American History class
which combines a
game show format
with a new remote control
technology called e-Clicks.
>>A, Colorado, B-
>>Karen: I notice that
the kids really enjoy it
and I've actually compared test
scores after I've done reviews
with the e-Clicks and with
scores where we haven't done it
and their scores
are actually better.
>>Or is it D, Troubelist?
>>Karen: Then it's good
for me because I can go in,
print the results, and I can
see who is having problems
with what area and I can
cover it again if I need to.
>>Tell me why Wyoming
wanted to have women vote?
>>Student: Most of the men were
leaving so they brought women in
and gave them rights to vote
so they would bring the-
it would bring all the
men back to the state.
>>It helps you learn because
it get everybody involved.
It's fun or whatever so we
can just you know all be-
>>Together, interact, yeah.
>>Narrator: At Harrison
students often get a chance
to interact with
outside experts.
>>Expert: Usually you can
do that by rapid profiling.
It's computer generated.
It's got two lasers.
>>Narrator: In this computer-ed
tech class students get advice
on their individual
computer designs
from an expert in plastics.
The buttons are in the eyes.
The right one is the
distraught button
and when you push it it pops
out of his mouth and it's kind
of like he's sticking
his tongue out.
>>Expert: That's probably one
of the cheapest designs
you probably could come
up with that here.
That's a good one.
>>Angela: We are going
to actually plot points
at the edges of every
building at the corners,
and then find the distance in
between, and then we're going
to create what from ArcView?
>>Maps.
>>Angela: Okay very
good, excellent.
>>Narrator: In this
sophomore math class, seventh
and eighth graders from nearby
North Gulfport Middle School are
the visiting experts teaching
the older Harrison students how
to use GPS devices.
>>This shows you
the coordinates.
There's the north coordinate.
There's the west coordinate.
>>Angela: The students in eighth
grade are just beginning to grow
and mature and so
for them to be able
to show older students is
just an incredible experience
for them.
>>The northwest corner.
Yeah.
>>So write down "30 degrees".
>>For latitude, longitude,
or elevation?
>>Latitude.
>>Angela: I have students
who are high achievers.
We've got some that are low
achievers and we've got some
in the middle and once they get
their hands on this technology
that just doesn't even matter.
They rise up to the standard
that you set for them
and this is something
that's new, it's innovative,
and one day many of these
kids will be doing this
for their career.
>>What was it, 30?
Uh-huh.
>>At this point you should
know which types are probes
and what data collection
you're going to be making.
>>Narrator: In an outdoor
science classroom built
by students preparations
are underway
for the weekly lab assignment.
After a 15 minute trek
on the school's nature
trail students stop
at specific points along the
stream to take water samples.
The data they collect and
analyze is then passed
on to local water
quality agencies.
>>How cold is it?
>>We're at three point eight.
>>Donnie: One way that
you can excite kids is
by getting them outside
of the classroom,
letting them get their
hands on something
and get a feel of
what's going on.
>>Take your one milliliter
of water, pull your film up,
place it on the center,
lay your film back down
and just run your
finger across it.
That's all you've got to do.
>>When you can take kids out and
actually show them something,
let them participate, let
them figure out how to do it
on their own, and then let them
interpret what they figure out,
then it has real
meaning for them.
>>So you're doing PH over time?
Um-hum.
>>Donnie: So within a minute
it's realistic to expect
that you would collect
900, 1,000 data sets?
>>Geez, okay.
>>Donnie: Okay?
>>Those are the kinds of skills
that I think kids need,
analytical skills.
Not just simple memorization
or comprehension.
You know we need to take them
beyond that level to being able
to explain their reason.
>>It's a good water-quality
indicator so
and then the crawfish are
under fair water quality
so I guess the water
down there is okay.
>>Teacher: And then
you're going to graph it?
>>Narrator: For district
technology coordinator,
Charlotte this is
the kind of learning
that makes the challenge
of technology integration
worth the effort.
>>Charlotte: I love to
watch the students learn.
I like to see the
light bulb go off.
I like to see the teachers
feel successful that yes!
When you know you did it, that
spark, when you see that happen,
when you see the classroom gel,
when you see the
students sparkle,
when you have them running
up to you and they want to be
at school and they
want to learn,
you know that you've done
what you're supposed to do
because learning is life-long
and learning is exciting
and it's fun, but
it's also personal.
And we try to make
learning personal
in Harrison County Schools.
[Students cheering]
>> For more information
on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org